bonjour bonjour factor bonjour françois
bonjour facteur est chaud pas vrai vous
voulez boire quelque chose je vous
l'offre c'est pas drôle on voit bien une
limonade j'aime aussi julie ça va
vraiment énorme
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je ne sais pas
je me suis trompé de bouteille c'est la
lessive pour nettoyer le coach vous
voulez quelque chose donc non non merci
ça suffit comme ça on va dit donc aux
kings aviez déjà pas le moral 1 et oui
facteur depuis que casimir est parti en
voyage l'île aux enfants n'est plus tout
à fait la même on a l'impression que le
jardin c'est pas pour moi que vous dites
sont bien sûr que non pas car au
contraire c'est très agréable de vous
voir rires vous vous êtes toujours de
bonnes idées même quand je vous fait
voir de la lessive
je dis toujours il vaut mieux être gros
et de bonne humeur que malgré triste là
vous avez bien raison facteurs part oui
j'y pense et j'ai de lettre aux romains
oui françois et j'ai reconnu l'écriture
de
cazilhac mois que signifie qu'il a pu
mais c'est bien
cher françois recherche julie je fais un
voyage merveilleux à le pen moi j'ai
toujours eu envie de partir comme ça sur
un bateau tout seul à la découverte des
terres nouvelles jamais un homme c'est
vrai ça que tu es en nous mais c'est
terminé données pardonnez moi je rêvais
un petit peu je vous en prie bon je
continue
j'arrive par le prochain bateau signé
kazim est le prochain bateau c'est dans
deux jours mais c'est formidable
quasiment tous les mois ça nous remet
dans ta lettre tu parlais du prochain
bateau wen
pour sûr que la neige gelée un peu
oublié dans mon sac ah bah tant mieux
comme samara il assure qu'un avenir
casimir connais toi qu'on te voit une
étoile supplémentaire
c'étaient les salopards et lui laissait
pas me laisser un mot et je crois que le
facteur a raison il faut lui laisser
raconter tous en voyage oui j'ai plein
de souvenirs de vue que c'est vrai les
enfants vous venez habiter vous sera
rien à 17 heures la partie verte voilà
voilà assis dans l'herbe
voilà le monde est installé tu viens ce
pays tout le monde a une place la gale
est ironique venez venez
casimir va nous raconter tout son voyage
d'abord je suis parti dans une belle
montagne beaucoup il y avait des bas
attendez j'ai j'ai oublié le nom mais
j'ai rapporté plaint d'un plein de
bruits de souvenirs de vacances dans ma
malle magique à bord s'est lui même ou
des sacs écouter à nos côtés ça écoutez
bien les enfants et c'était bien
écouter
vous reconnaissez qu'est ce qu'il entend
la cigale le sol doit comme ça on n'est
pas l'école
qu'est-ce que c'était des vignals s'est
laissé gagner s'il ya ce que c'est ça et
ça c'est dans quel pays les cigarettes
dites moi
en france mais dans quelle partie de la
france en réponse au
projet parmi les parents c'est ça casino
avant et après avec ap je suis parti
dans une autre région oui où j'ai
entendu des décors des oreilles ou à
écouter la magic la belgique
on
a demandé aussi paris qu'il faut c'est
un petit peu c'est tellement beau c'est
tellement beau qu'on s'y croirait à
chaque fois on écoutait un petit moment
après dit ouah jean-françois démo est
donc les moitiés c'est la mère de ma
mère c'est au bord de la mer et à terre
la mer
s'est entendu les enfants on écoute un
petit peu c'est tellement beau on se
croirait il a été signé après quelques
aberrations suis allé dans une une
grande grande quoi à réécouter
m
bâti mais en quasi nil une voiture c'est
pas tout à fait ça on entend des bruits
de voitures nous y at il des huit
voitures sur l'autoroute il y en a
partout mais particulièrement sur ocana
dans une noix et mais
j'étais lent dans un village nommé où il
y en a énormément dans une ville
d'ajdabiya est en vacances dans une
grande ville juste après la combi je
suis parti quelques jours dans une
petite dépayser ou à écouter écouter on
écoute
voilà c'est ça mais coûteuse parce que
c'est une bascule mailing
une poule il a beaucoup même des poules
je crois
qu'elle générera près maintenant une
ferme c'est sa voiture était quasi mis
ensuite un jour j'ai vu une 1h il arrête
tout et on tenait là où il ya beaucoup
de mémoire
me l'on écoute qu'on écoute un petit en
écoute
dans une course automobile une bonne
course automobile voilà vous aimez les
murs de nos villes vous aimez ça les
gars sont allés après suite j'ai pu j'ai
été dans un pays où il y avait été
oui
mais d'anciens habitants des montagnes
qu'est ce que c'est que ça qu'est ce
qu'il a entendu
vous avez raison c'est parce entendu
c'est presque détendu non c'est pas dans
la d
c'est ça c'est exactement ça christine
des tam-tams détailler quelle paix à liu
c'était tout à l'heure les after the way
avais tu as raison effectivement il y en
a aussi à tahiti ouais et alors le
dernier giro il y a eu quelque chose de
deux ans et coûté ce qui est bien viager
jour de tes vacances voilà oui
un petit peu on écoute des salles voilà
y'a pas plus un orage a érigé moteur est
ce que c'était un orage et qu'est-ce
qu'il ya pendant leur âge plus il pleut
non mais qu'est-ce qu'il ya aussi bon
que ce bruit la chaleur
vous avez très bien répondu c'était du
tonnerre casimir le fait un très beau
voyage prend mais
le dernier mot n'a pas eu de chance ni
raison mais les autres choses françois
cusset j'ai voyagé avec des chants
vraiment très désagréable au bout de tes
gens désagréables mais qu'est ce qu'il
te disait parce qu'ils étaient très mal
poli très impliqués dans des rixes à 10h
écoute ce qu'il visait en écoutant
l'écoutent et
et casimir c'est ça quitte à choquer
ouais et alors
et voilà grand prix de propreté juges
désignés et millecamps pas
à savoir une belle affiche c'est une
belle revanche l'acteur jean-françois ou
qu'est-ce qui vous a
je viens de nettoyer mon grenier il y
avait plein de vieux objets tout
poussiéreux je me suis bien amusé mais
je crois que j'ai jamais été aussi sale
temps pour sûr à 100 ça tombe mal sain
mais pourquoi qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on va vous alors vous voulez
vraiment pas de mémoire m regardez grand
prix de propreté
et juges désignés et mis le cap des
rives 1 je l'avais complètement oublié
vous savez le le plus peiné ce sera
casimir le lui qui vous porte si au 1 il
sera vraiment déçu il croit que je suis
toujours parfait alors quand il d'avoir
que j'ai oublié le grand prix de
propreté ou y médite dans d'un autre
côté c'est pas plus mal comme ça il
verra que tout le monde peut faire des
erreurs pour sûr ça je discute pas
mais voilà et ce après leur donner un
casimir
effet après mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive
que gémir regarde moi ben oui je te vois
quel génie mais tu es tout seul oui
juste le jour du grand plus de propreté
mais c'est justement à cause du grand
prix williams et enfin calme-toi casimir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé tout va
j'étais très propre et puis j'ai
rencontré monsieur du snop qui était
plus propre que moi alors casimir
casimir toi tu nous as fait quelque
chose de très mal an non j'ai simplement
mis sur sa peau oui un grand saut avec
de la colle et des bio papier à à oslo
avec de l'est et c'est toi qui a reçu le
sceau sur la tête
mais quoi toi aussi tu as reçu un seau
un avenant nos machines est jeune et why
et mon grenier et j'avais complètement
oublié que c'était le jour du grand prix
de propreté un bon écoutez je crois que
vous avez juste le temps le concours a
lieu que dans un moment rien alors allez
vite vous nettoyer et à tout à l'heure
en ligue amateur
kazimierz nettoyer
[Musique]
cela pour ce fait les oreilles est bien
celle là oui demain à nîmes a fait des
facteurs j'avais oui oui alors attendez
jacques oui ça peut elle et moi et moi
j'arrive juste maintenant casimir parce
que j'avais terminé sa chute j'ai eu
peur d'être en retard les niveaux
casimir pouvoir marcher tout comme ça là
comme ça va aller comme cela pour quoi
mais c'est pour ne pas soulever de la
poussière qui risquerait de me salir il
faut dire que tu vraiment propre je ne
t'ai jamais eu ici
oui bon ben alors j'ai gagné ah non non
non il faut que je t'ai exalead bon là
allons-y
dis toi oui comment désigner vu le
vainqueur ou ceux très simple je décerne
plusieurs fois les élèves et un pour
chaque partie du corps un sketch
règlement chèque à rire et les rend
ensuite expliqué ensuite je voudrais
ensuite j'additionne jeu total bressoux
les points remportés par les concurrents
de l'ue et soulevé canal+ il va à gagner
automatiquement le le grand prix de
propre évidemment pas le dit penser aux
malheurs jardin oui oui voilà excuse moi
alors première catégorie 1re et ribéry
[ __ ] cheveux les plus propres
en mai casimir c'est vrai tu n'as pas de
cheveux j'en suis désolé tu tu ne peut
pas concourir à moi même catégorie au
monde
attends attends attends voyons la
deuxième catégorie les oreilles les plus
propres
mais casimir tu n'a pas d'oreille
vous savez bien coller casimiri donc
jamais une oreille je suis complètement
désolé
bon 3e qui a fait venir c'est pas de
chance voyons peu à 3e catégorie dont
les plus propres ap alors ventre tu es
dans casimir enfin enfin factor vous
savez très bien que casimir n'a pas deux
ans à réglementer un geste l'axé c'est
robin qui je suis assez d'accord avec
vous un sens c'est vrai
bon attendez je crois qu'il avait vu oui
voilà il ya une dernière catégorie à
bord celle là va peut-être sauvé casimir
espérer la main et les cinq doigts
y en a que quatre de ses six pattes ont
droit à casimir cet endroit
le règlement dit bien cinq doigts oui
pour écouter jean
reynal fait vraiment vous avez raison
kazemi a été éliminé une façon
totalement injuste n'est pas
ministre rd3 du temps euros le règlement
c'est le règlement cinéma alors
évidemment aller via kg myriam ray avec
moi ou imaginaires casimir nous pour
nous tous le plus propre c'est toi
maintenant donc telle 24 févr oui même
si je rentrais de mon remporté en tant
qu il
ya quelques lignes que je n'ai pas lu
ou témoin si le concurrent n'a pas de
cheveux dit dedans ni d'oreilles et
qu'il n'a que quatre doigts on pourra
les remplacer par des taches rouges
grave mais jamais la
faille en a et des taches jaunes mc
donald s amarrer hélas et une crête
rouge un voile à
ghazir bravo je te désigne comme le
vainqueur du grand prix de propos tes
bras
à venir s'est
vu alors qu'est ce que j'ai gagné à
temps a gâché j'ai la liste des 10 et 20
des prix est bien cassée comme une
brosse à cheveux une prends ça dans de
jolies boucles d'oreilles et un peigne
en écales au nom
voir